you saw for real like your heart would
it look like
oh you bet it smell like a me was it
it was so fluffy ah I thought I was
gonna die are you okay yeah I'm fine
are you
[Applause]
sorry went a little mama bear Anya you
know I heard a scream and yeah shortly
after you and your brother were born
your father and I divorced and we each
took one son obviously haha I got second
pick I have a twin brother my brother
[Music]
finally meeting you you're discovered a
solarium so how are things career-wise
haha great you what these Most Wanted
village just get away you're fired
so so great crashing it brought you here
to continue the family business the only
is in your blood and broken boobs I left
that life behind me I understand hmm I
wonder what this does
holy-moly become a villain Mogambo
Oh what did you guys do today there's
always a blinder nothing
put my
Oh what about that
for what Oh girls make you learn to
appreciate me differentiate we've been
waiting a long time so what once was it
was so fluffy I thought I was from a day
[Music]
so you two are villains name ah I mean
hello sweetie Oh hug you down over
kissing
[Music]